hi everyone i'm really really happy to
be here speaking in front of real people
not in to you know the void that is the
internet
um i'm talking about the myth of
neutrality or how ai is widening social
divides
few words about myself even though i've
already been introduced machine learning
engineer at innovex there's some
colleagues of mine out there so come
talk to us if you like
and i also enjoy
baking dancing and drawing and laughing
unfortunately though the talk that i'm
giving today is not really a laughing
matter so you'll find out why
imagine
you're driving down the highway
when you're suddenly being pulled over
by the police
they check your driver's license in
their system specifically the picture
and they find that it matches the one of
a person
who is wanted for armed robbery
so what's going on
it might be something like this so the
cops checked your license and they fed
your picture
into an algorithmic system who's backed
which is backed by a database of mug
shots by people that are wanted for
certain crimes
and they find a match for your face
and so the officers will lock you up and
you're going to jail
and if you think this is actually a
drastic example
well this has happened to at least three
black men in the united states in just a
recent few years
and so my talk wants to shed light on
how things like this can actually happen
and you know where along the way of
creating ai systems that we have many
pitfalls basically to uncover
and to begin with i want to look at the
overall ai landscape that sort of
informs this development
and
i want to start by looking at the
sectors in which ai is being developed
and first of all let's look at big tech
because they have unarguably the most
money and the most power to develop
these algorithms and deep neural
networks and they're sort of you know
pursuing certain agendas
that for example community and
government wouldn't pursue
and then there's the military
um
who also have always been interested in
the ai development
and we'll find out a little bit more
about this and they sort of
steer this into
a direction that is more a surveillance
driven
then the next point is that we have a
yeah let's say homogeneous demographic
pretty much in the i.t sector
there's basically a lot of men in the in
the sector and this is not only going
i'm not talking about binary gender
and i'm also talking about other axes of
identities such as race or ethnicity or
religious background and basically the
others are the little unicorns that i
painted here so this also informs
which
solutions are pursued using ai
technology
third of all there's also a geographic
imbalance so we have the us and china
sort of leading this arms race to to get
to the forefront of innovation in this
sector whereas the others are a little
speck of dust as you can see on the
slide
and now
now that we have this
bird's eye view we can start looking at
the standard ai development process and
this will sort of lead you through my
talk and i will start with research and
funding then go over to data collection
and labeling specifically looking at
image data sets large image state image
datasets that are used for deep learning
applications
and then go on with training and testing
specifically the metrics that are used
and how they can be problematic and then
finally look at the deployment and how
this solution can lead to problems in
the real world
so i think it
makes sense to look at the birth of ai
the birth of this term
artificial intelligence the term was
coined at the dartmouth workshop in 1956
by which was organized in attendance by
this amazingly diverse group of people
that you can see on the slide
and these researchers believe that fully
intelligent machines would be a you know
possibility or a reality rather until
the mid 70s
i'm not sure you've seen any terminators
yet i haven't so
you know
this didn't happen yet
but i think it's interesting to look at
their you know what they think about
intelligence so a quote from the
workshop proposed was every aspect of
learning or any other feature of
intelligence can be so precisely
described that a machine can be made to
simulate it well maybe you want to think
about that quote i actually don't
believe that it is pos this is possible
because we as humans haven't really
established what exactly intelligence is
really we have some iq tests and so on
but this doesn't check for everything
that we think intelligent entails
so
yeah let's move on to the funding part
actually so like i said earlier
who's funding the research well first of
all
military and intelligence agencies
especially darpa which is short for
defense advanced research project agency
and they were and still are a major
source of funding in ai's early days and
they also fund other stuff like for
example they've been
funding the modern vaccine
but they are still pumping money into
this and we can see on the next slide
that also the department of defense is
actually a huge spender when it comes to
ai
so this is this shows the u.s contract
spending on ai by government agency in
the year 2020
and this is not money that is spent
internally by these agencies on
development but rather given to
third-party contractors the for-profit
firms
that create ai solutions for the
government and the dod by far like the
spending by far outweighs any other
agency in the u.s
one of the for-profit companies
that a lot of money is being spent on
specifically by law enforcement agencies
is clearview ai some of you might have
heard from them in the news
they are a u.s based company that sells
access to its biometric identification
software
and the way it works is basically you
give them a photo of a person that you
want information on and their software
will give you all the other photos that
that they've got of this person and
possibly more information like their
name and address and so on
and to create this product they actually
went ahead and they scraped more than 10
billion photographs from twitter
facebook and instagram
these were public images hence
the ceo of clearview says well all the
information we collect is collected
legally and it is all publicly available
information
well now i want you to think about
the last time you might have gone to a
party that went really out of hand
and you got really embarrassingly drunk
and somebody took a picture in a really
embarrassing moment of you and put it on
facebook without any privacy
restrictions would you want that image
to be in clever eyes database
i don't think i would
so
i'm not sure it's just information that
we're talking about
now let's look at big tech big tech
argue unarguably has
a lot of money so they're buying
everything they can get their hands on
and this slide shows um what tech giants
have been um of the tech giant's
acquisitions um that cost them more than
one billion dollars so everything else
they bought isn't even on the slide
right
um between 2000 and 2020
and as we can see um they have been
buying more and more for more and more
money over the time and this first of
all creates a problem because they're
monopolizing a lot of different markets
and also
steering research directions right so
they have this this really has a bad
influence on you know uh the economy as
well
and secondly they're leading to an ai
brain drain at u.s universities or
universities in north america generally
in this slide we can see the number of
ai factually departures in north america
between 2004 and 2019
and as you can see the numbers have been
steadily rising over the years so all
these faculty
have left
u.s universities to go and work for big
tech specifically right
and this this creates
at least two problems i can see so first
of all these universities are left
without their top factually meaning they
will have less money because less
funding will get you know secured
through these people
and then secondly what the um
people that made this study government
and gin found out
was that
the students that are left behind at
these universities
founded less startups or less innovative
startups which is again bad economically
and you know some of you might be saying
that you know but google and all these
other big tech companies they're doing a
lot of research they're building these
large language models and so on so they
are really they do really have a
positive impact on research as a whole
but i'd like to say to this that also
the research within some of these
companies that at least does not seem
entirely independent as we can see from
the quote that i'm going to show you now
so this is a quote by a senior manager
at google
while they were reviewing a paper on
recommendation algorithms written by
google scientists
before publication so they said
take great care to strike a positive
tone
this is generally not something that you
would hear in a scientific review
process or you shouldn't at least right
so this tells you that google has
on top of you know the scientific review
process when you send your paper to a
journal and you get a double blind
review
they have an additional process which is
kind of weird and also you know they're
kind of steering this research in
certain directions again and one of the
most prominent examples of this is
actually
what happened to these two women timnit
gabriel and margaret mitchell
these women used to be the co-leads of
the ethical ai team at google until the
end of 2020 beginning of 2021
and they um wanted to publish a
paper that criticized among other things
google's large language models
and well like i said they don't work
there anymore right and if you want to
know more about this story because it's
quite shocking actually then read this
article that i've linked in there you
can find the slides on the conference
website
secondly
let's look into data collection and
labeling and we cannot really
get around this
imagenet data set when we talk about
this so
imagenet is the image classification
dataset is basically what started out
the whole deep learning era that we're
finding ourselves in right now
and it contains more than 14 million
images in more than 20 000 categories
and basically when we talk about image
classification what we mean is we have
images and each image has at least one
label associated with it which we call
ground truth so for an image of a cat
you would have cat as a label for
instance
and the goal of the authors when they
created uh imagenet was to map out the
entire world of objects which is
ambitious to say the least
um where did these images come from
well they came from the internet so the
authors
scraped the images from search engines
and photo sharing websites
and there's also images of people in
there
so did they ask these people for consent
nope
they didn't
and actually they just looked at
whether images had creative commons
licenses and if they did they were like
okay well that's a free-for-all buffet
let's just uh you know use these images
and they say like many other people
nowadays that are creating these large
data sets well if somebody doesn't want
to be in our data set they can just
write us an email right
but you don't know whether you're in the
data set you just have no clue
and how were these images labeled you
know then the labels need to come from
somewhere and this is actually quite
interesting so they were based the
labels are based on another data set
called wordnet which was created in 1985
at princeton university and it's
basically a hierarchical word database
and so they use these as the basis for
for these images for labels for these
images
and put tasks up on amazon mechanical
turk which is an online platform where
gig workers or ghost workers as they're
called
will have simple tasks like for instance
they get an image and a few labels and
they have to pick which label fits the
best or multiple labels
and so
yeah with this approach they created
image image net data set
which was finally published in 2009
and now i want you to imagine you're one
of these people that are labeling these
images and you see
an image of a person
and now you have to choose a label from
among these
so
this is a word cloud
showing which are
arguably some of the most offensive
labels in the person category of
imagenet we have words like pervert bad
person
loser call girl and some of which i'd
rather not read out loud
and i'm asking myself at least like i
have many questions about this but
how
would you know what a bad person looks
like from just looking at an image that
seems to be like opening the floodgates
for lots of bad stereotyping right
and then also second of all why would an
algorithm which is what is the use case
for an algorithm to to know what a cool
girl looks like
not
sure also
weddings don't look like this everywhere
and if you're confused now
let's look at this so we have four
images which all show people getting
married right and these uh images were
labeled by neural network which was
trained on the open images data set and
on the for the first three pictures you
can see that the labels actually fit to
what a human might describe this image
as so we have ceremony wedding bride
groom and so on but the last image is
labeled as person people even though it
shows a couple getting married
and what we can see here is that a lot
of image data sets but also other data
sets used in deep learning have a large
school geographically so here for the
two
data sets open images and imagenet we
can see that most of the pictures were
actually taken in north america or come
from north america and europe whereas
the rest of the world is just vastly
underrepresented which creates exactly
those kind of problems like we saw or
imagine you know a tesla suddenly
driving in new delhi when it's trained
in los angeles how's that going to work
right
next
let's look at the training and testing
and specifically the metrics that we
often use
to check the performance of the
algorithms
and i want to start with
talking about a landmark study which is
called gender shades
in 2018 joy bolamini and timnit gabriel
investigated by season commercial binary
gender classification systems
joy's work was inspired by her own
experience of not being recognized by
open source face detection software you
can see an image of her on the slide
and as a black woman she actually had to
wear a white mask for the system to
finally detect her face
and she thought okay how are these
algorithms dealing with different skin
colors how does the performance you know
differ for people with different skin
colors and so she decided to create a
data set of lighter and darker skinned
people
to check this binary gender
classification system or
multiple of those three to be exact
and so she divided this data set into
four groups light of skate lighter
skinned female in male and darker
skinned female and males and she checked
three commercial systems
and what you can see here are the mean
accuracies for gender classification at
first glance
and so you might think okay well
microsoft has 93.1
phase plus plus 89.5 and ibm 86.5
that doesn't seem too bad right
but then when you look at the subgroup
accuracies
you can see
vastly different results
so for the lighter male group
you get a hundred percent accuracy for
microsoft 99.2 for face plus plus and
99.7 for ibm whereas the darker female
group has a lot less accuracy and the
largest gap is at 34.4 percent for the
ibm system
and just to make clear how bad this
result is so 65.3 accuracy if i throw a
coin
right on any of these images i will get
roughly 50 right
this is bad
this is a really bad accuracy
so what this tells us is that a single
success metric does not tell the whole
story sometimes we really have to dig
deeper
and gabriel's work then motivated many
other researchers to assess biases and
try to build fairer systems
and some people actually went ahead and
said okay let's you know grab the
problem at least roots and create fairer
data sets and one of these you know
fairer data sets apparently is divide
diversity in phases which was created by
ibm with the goal of advancing the study
of accuracy and fairness and facial
recognition
and what they did was they
took images that were again scraped from
flicker you know without any consent and
so on and they annotated them with
facial measurements such as facial width
and height and you know how far your
nose and mouth are apart and then they
let gig workers again assign
perceived age race and gender
yeah
the reasoning behind this was that the
measurements allow better assessment of
accuracy and fairness and more
fine-grained representation
representation of facial diversity
but i keep asking myself whether
diversity is really just
you know represented by a variety of
face shapes
or whether diversity means you know
binary agenda assigned by you know some
gig worker somewhere in the world
ai creators are the ones
um that decide about the classification
system right we create the boxes
that other people are being put into
and some people don't fit these boxes so
they are labeled as other
what this means is that you know it's
centralizing power and craig crawford
has actually put this very nicely in her
book atlas of ai
the practice of classification is
centralizing power the power to decide
which differences make a difference
now let's get to the final part
deployment before i
say a few words about fairness
um i think hiring and firing is actually
a very interesting topic when we look at
you know what's going on in the world
today because when we look at
traditional recruiting
the way we're used to applying for jobs
is that
we you know see a see a job somewhere a
job posting that we like and we
send our application to the company and
if they like it we will get invited to
an interview hopefully speaking to a
person
and if they like us we get hired if not
we won't
today it's a little bit different
because many of us are using online
services like linkedin for instance
and the first time we come into um you
know we get we get in touch with
algorithms there are it's very early on
when linkedin sends us alerts or emails
regularly with open job postings which
are you know specifically catered for
our location and our skill set and so on
whatever information we offer linkedin
so we might not actually get to see all
the jobs that are out there so they're
pre-filtered
secondly you know when you see a job
that you like you apply for it at the
company but they might now not be have
you know using a human to go through all
the cvs but they might be using an
algorithmic solution for this
and you know your cv might be sorted out
or not by the algorithm
well if you get through and you're lucky
you again get to talk to a human during
your interview
but if you're unlucky
then you might get to talk to a service
like higher view and this is a u.s based
company
which created you know a software where
you sit in front of your laptop at home
and you talk to a voice chat bot which
is asking you questions that the company
you know things are relevant for the job
and they record everything you say and
do they look at your emotions and you
know your voice pitch and so on
and hopefully also about the content
what you're saying i'm not actually sure
and yeah so the algorithm finally
decides whether you're a good fit or not
and the hope is that this will you know
get rid of all the biases that we humans
inevitably have
but i just see layers of problems with
this because first of all
if you talk to a chatbot you cannot
really tell it to clarify something if
you didn't get the question right it
will not understand what you say you can
ask that a human and they might rephrase
the question
and also you will get no feedback after
after the rejection if you're lucky you
might get something like a point score
from one to five well you scored 3.5 out
of five so you didn't get the job sorry
but how do you know how the score is
calculated right you simply have no
information
and this also opens the door for you
know discrimination that will you know
you will you're not able to prove if
you've if you've been discriminated
against and so you have no way to
challenge this decision
and then third which i find you know
most like probably the most scary point
of this is the scalability of it because
in the good old days you you went to a
company and there was an hr person if
they didn't like you you know you went
to a different company with a different
hr person
but now if you imagine that there's a
single vendor providing this system to
all the companies that you're applying
at
you're screwed
you're not you're not going to get the
job right
well
and also how do these algorithms
actually determine whether someone is a
good fit for a job
amazon has actually tried to create a
hiring tool
and this was being trained on resumes of
applicants over a 10-year period
and as i've said you know the it sector
is a very homogenous
place in society so
they actually realized that this tool
discriminated against women
and they tried to fix it by making it
blind to certain words that indicated
gender in the cvs
but they soon realized that
this didn't work because the system kept
finding ways to infer a person's gender
from other seemingly unrelated factors
so proxy variables right so
yeah no way to fix this one so they took
the reasonable decision to trash the
system
however a few years later so last year i
read this article
amazon now seems to think that firing
people with algorithms is a great idea
specifically they're drivers in the us
and if you really want to be you know
want to get scared then you know read
the story that i've linked in here
well
but sometimes people say okay well there
needs to be some kind of solution to
this we need to build fairness into the
process we need to sort of
metrify you know fairness or what we
think is fair into the algorithms in the
systems that we built
and um i want you to imagine now that
you had to build a fair hiring algorithm
for it specifically and let's say the
goal is to get more women into it you
know
and you have this
applicant pool you have 20
applications and you have 10 open
positions right
and we have two groups we have female
which are the circles and male the
triangles and then we have some kind of
extra feature like where that person is
qualified um for example has a degree
and you know an it or tech related
sector and i'm sorry for the binary this
is just to make it less complex i know
the world is more complicated than that
so the first fairness metric that we
could use um
is called demographic parity
and this means
that the probability to get hired should
be approximately equal
for both groups
and if we now draw a rectangle about the
people that will get the job we could
for instance
you know look at these candidates and
you know get them give them the job
but some of you might say well you know
but now
we don't really have the most qualified
people in there right
uh you know there's one woman with a
degree which didn't get the job to
without a degree which got a job that
seems
kind of odd
maybe we should take qualification into
account when we
think about fairness
and so we could use equal opportunity
which is similar but it says probably
the probability to get higher should be
approximately equal for both groups
given that the individuals in these
groups are qualified
and now
we have
one woman that is qualified and we have
10 men that are qualified
and if we draw a line around
the people that we could hire it might
look something like this
so we have 10
slots filled
and so this means one out of one
qualified women gets a job which is 100
and 9 out of 10 qualified men get the
job which is 90 but this is as good as
it gets where we just want to fill 10
spaces you know
but now
there's a problem with this as well
because in the underrepresented group
specifically only the
individuals that are the most privileged
anyway might get the job
uh so the women that come from ex for
example high socioeconomic backgrounds
and this is especially in germany we
know that this is actually the case
right we know that people who whose
parents have been you know have an
academic background are much more likely
to themselves become academics and get a
degree than people whose parents don't
have an academic degree
so this also seems kind of unfair
and
so some of you might say well maybe we
shouldn't look into opportunities but
maybe we should make the outcomes equal
so we could look we could look at
um equality of outcomes also called
affirmative action
and that could be saying you know there
must be a 50 50 split between the groups
after hiring
and when you think about it this
you know we have 10 open spaces but we
can actually not fill them all because
when we just look at this fairness
metric
we can just hire for uh eight
individuals because we only have four
women in the whole group
and then again some of you might say
well but now we have three
unqualified women in favor of so many
other qualified men so how is this fair
for them because they've you know even
if their parents had an academic
background they still worked you know to
get this degree so how do you how do we
solve that
and then secondly even if you think this
is a good
way of solving this problem so this is
something that you know relates to
quotas having quotas in place
think about it this way so if you as one
of these women get into a place where
there's a male majority an overwhelming
majority they might just take you for
token
tokens you know that uh join us without
you know doing anything for yourself you
know to get there
so
i'm wondering i don't know whether you
have an opinion on that but i've been
wondering which one of these is fair
right so
is the demographic parity equal
opportunity or affirmative action or
something else that i didn't specify
here
some of these are actually
you know they cannot be some of these
metrics cannot be had at the same time
and um
what i'm trying to say or get at here is
that fairness is inherently a political
decision
so
the context
really matters right we cannot just get
like do this checklist approach to say
okay this fairness metric will work in
this context but we really have to think
about what we're what we're dealing with
here and also different individuals will
have different
opinions on what is fair
and
really we should not outsource these
political decisions only to the select
few developing ai systems and i'm
counting myself in that into that group
as well i'm also a very privileged
person
because if we do that if we keep on
doing that we will end up with what i
call the ai feedback poop
right
to recap what i've been talking about so
we have this research and funding on the
top left which is driven by military and
big tech interests for-profit and
surveillance right
and then we have these image and other
data set collection practices where
people are not being asked for their you
know their content is just scraped off
the internet and they don't even know
what's happening with it and this then
informs the algorithms that we build and
on top of that we choose metrics that
sort of
favor the majority group and you know
don't care about the minority groups
that are in the data set
and then this leads to um deployments or
ai being used in the real world that
really harms the well-being and life of
real people like in the you know example
that i showed at the beginning of the
three guys being arrested because their
image matched you know some image in a
database somewhere
and the problem with this last use case
is that this might actually be used
again
to train further algorithms because it
might be used as a data point in a
predictive policing system right so this
wrong arrest you cannot guarantee that
the wrong wrongfully made arrest will
then be taken out of of this data set
because they will someone will go ahead
and say oh three three years down the
line we actually realize this person is
innocent
this you know i don't believe that
happens
and um
to finish on a bit of a you know what we
can do about this notes uh let's look at
um my advice for everyone first of all
really stay informed about what's going
on don't only read the stories
that say you know ai has superhuman
capabilities and such and such area but
um really think about what are the use
cases that you want ai to be used in
society and which are the ones who
really don't want ai to be used in
then secondly join and organize
collectives there's a there's many great
collectives um i've i have some in my
references later
that are for example fighting against
mass surveillance and they're fighting
for algorithmic accountability
and you can donate to these
organizations as well
and also vote for politicians that
really want to you know tackle this
problem
and that see that
you know ai can create problems and that
we also need to stop this monopolization
of big tech because this will just you
know get worse down the line
then my advice for folk in machine
learning
be critical right really whether it's
about your own or someone else's data or
metrics or algorithm
don't just look at one-dimensional
accuracy for instance you know and don't
just be satisfied if someone says okay
let's lose use this fairness metric this
will solve all of our problems
then
it should be moral first math second so
it's really
important that we identify harms and
consequences before we formalize
anything we should really have
actually actually bake this into the
process of developing ai
and to do this i think it's important
that we also involve other human beings
because many of us just don't know about
the lived realities of people that are
already suffering the consequences and
harms of these systems being deployed
and here you should really talk or try
to talk to affected communities because
they they might already know what it's
like to be surveilled and you know
others other bad stuff happening to them
and also talk to social scientists
because they have been doing a lot of
research especially also qualitative
research which the machine learning
community has been ignoring for decades
and
i think it's important to not only look
at quantity but also quality right
and listen and learn
from these people
and with that i say thank you very much
for being here and listening to me rant
about the stage of ai
and i hope you have some questions for
me you can find me on twitter
in this handle and
yeah also check out my references i've
got a lot of
great books that you should read if you
if you like reading books or if you're
more into
podcasts i've got all the stuff all the
good stuff series and so on so check out
my slides if you want to know more
and also
you know down the rabbit hole scientific
literature for the ones who really you
know
really want to get a cheese grit to you
yeah thanks
[Applause]
okay uh thanks for the talk
um
we have some online questions but i
think uh you can still submit some but i
think we'll also have time to yield some
questions from the audience before the
next
talk
um the first one is where can we find
the slides
on the python
data on the python website on my talk
website i guess so the google slides are
linked there great
and a bit more
to the topic of the talk is there any
change in the day-to-day work in machine
learning after so many books and
published research on ethics and machine
learning um
i would say
it's actually quite it's actually rather
a young discipline so
i would say so this gender shades paper
that i showed came out in 2018 so that's
only four years ago
and this was basically the breakthrough
for this whole field for people to
actually start um looking into this i
mean people have been looking into it
beforehand but sort of looking at how
subgroups demographic subgroups perform
or how the algorithms perform and then
that was sort of the first work that i
saw in this regard and now there's many
many more and there's conferences on
this scientific conferences and as we
can see there's also tracks at uh you
know
python conferences and probably our
conferences and so on so this is you
know a step in the right direction
but and generally i would say in terms
of
yeah day-to-day work
this is not really this is mostly an
afterthought in when we're developing ai
systems and that's that's the biggest
problem how do we actually also tell our
clients and our employers that this is a
topic that really you know needs to be
looked at and this is where regulation
comes in as well
okay those are all the questions we got
online so um does anyone here in the
room
have a question for our speaker
i
think i can just bring the mic to you
so thanks a lot for your nice talk was
very interesting i was wondering what
are the most important laws that we
might need to enact in order to
combat these problems that you have
raised
oh yeah
[Laughter]
i'm not uh yeah i'm not a lawyer right
um
but there is you know there is this uh
euai regulation draft that they've been
working on for the past three years or
so
and this might actually come into effect
in 2024 or 2025 maybe and this will be
like
a little bit like the gdpr so they will
have
massive fines for companies that go
against this and this is in my opinion
this is one step that needs to be you
know tackled
um
yeah but in terms of i think it's it's
diff it's a difficult question to answer
because
you have people in government deciding
about these things that are being
lobbied again by google and meta and so
on right
so they also want to you know have see
their interests uh in these laws and um
a lot of the times politicians just
don't know what they're dealing with
they don't know you know what's what's
happening with these with these laws and
what the effects would be and i think
many of us also can't foresee it because
there will always be like you know gray
areas that you can can be circumvented
but i think regulation is important and
also if if somebody goes against this
that they have to pay a lot of money is
an important thing but then i think
regulation can't only be the only answer
we also have to have like a civil
society who is really aware of this
problem so not only people that are
working in this algorithmic space but
also people that you know like your
grandma should care about this
and your parents should care about this
because surveillance will you know
matter to all of us
right and so this is important to just
spread the word and also show them these
examples and on what could be happening
in the near future and it's already
happening now
um we have another question from the
chat i'll uh
sprinkle that in um do you think that we
should actively push these thoughts when
working for clients how do you deal with
this
yeah
um
yes i think this is important
uh we also had this discussion very
recently at my workplace and this is
like sometimes also difficult to deal
with i think because
companies have an economic incentive to
do certain things right and so i think
it's sometimes clever to bring this
economic incentive together with these
ethical concerns right to say okay but
look two years or three years down the
line
um
all good
elevators now your time is
a bit of um yeah like two or three years
uh down the line this regulation will
come into place and then you need to be
ready because otherwise you'll pay fine
of 10 million euros and then they'll be
like oh
okay
maybe we should look into this
um we got another question about um
whether the slides are really uploaded i
will look into this uh okay uh ask the
organization
uh i'll check with the organizers but i
think okay yeah some time around today
they should be there if they are not
already or otherwise i can post them on
twitter after i talk sorry perfect
okay
hi so
my question is about the problem that
many of these problems that you
described actually tie back to issues
that are just present in our society
right so we get this data that is
inherently racist sexist whatever and
then the algorithms oftentimes just
reflect that and so my question is do
you think that we as a community just
need to make sure that we're not even
worse than this or do you think that we
should actively try to improve on this
standard and shape the underlying
society in a way
and if so aren't we then almost
reinforcing the same problem where we as
the select few actually then
start shaping the society of course in a
way that we think is right and just and
good but maybe not everyone disagrees
with this yes
yes we should
so to answer the first question i think
it's really important that people who
actually
know about this do
inform others right this is this is
really important
and yes i get um i get what you're
saying you know we we will also have
certain agendas right
um but if we don't share this
information this will actually be worse
right so this is this is not an option
right
um
and with regards to shaping society it's
not actually that easy
i mean like many people have tried for a
very long time
um to to make to make you know changes
be seen in the world around them and um
i think if just a few of us uh try to do
try to change something for the better
it will not it will not really have such
a big impact on society but we might get
the ball rolling you know and this is
this is important and also
keep in mind that like advocacy work or
you know uh that's
it's tiring right and you will get a lot
of you know a lot of people fighting
back because they don't really
understand the problem or they're in a
very privileged position like you know
big tech companies and they don't want
want
things to change in that way
i think we have time for
one final question i think
that one was first
thank you very much
i will just
suggest everybody to read super
interesting on how to really go to the
fairness of the date i don't know if
it's there probably
the authors
are there the last two yeah the last one
for sure
no it's
about how to it's true that we need to
convince politicians to do something
about it but the truth is that if you
don't convince society politicians will
not do anything about it and the
question i'm always asking myself
is people are annoyed by gdpr right now
and now you convince them that uploading
their pictures on facebook is actually
putting them inside all these databases
and this is
it's dangerous and it's bad and usually
what i get is i don't care i don't have
anything to hide and i was just
wondering if you have any strategy or
any anything when you discuss when you
try to inform people about this topic
yeah um
it is difficult some people will not be
convinced that's just
the way life is unfortunately i think
for gdpr what really what really sucked
about gdpr are the cookie banners i mean
come on
like who likes cookie banners right um
but i think having a lot of examples
that might relate to their lived reality
is also something that might help
convince them right and also you know um
it's a slow process right uh we have the
saying in german steeda trophen
so if you know if you keep the drip the
drops coming onto the stone it will at
some point you want to it will make a
cave
and um yeah maybe maybe also talk to
people around them that you can convince
that then can talk to them as well so
this is something you know if you get
the ball rolling at some point maybe
change will happen but i do not have a
recipe i do not have a checklist because
i think that's actually the wrong
approach i think we all have to find our
own way of dealing with this
okay thanks again for your talk